make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our video
series on the boys ah this one it's part
of the boys but it's actually kind of a
miniseries it stands on its own apart
from everything else
it doesn't really even stand on its own
right it kind of ties into everything
which really sort of begs the question
why was it releases a miniseries in the
first place you could probably skip over
it but I wouldn't suggest it and the
reason why is because this is probably
the most extreme example of how the
superheroes function in the heroes
universe right so what is up happening
here is initially you pick up in the
beginning with basically a homeland or
addressing the other media you know
standing out in front of the Capitol to
say alright guys so things are getting
ready to pop off right like there's some
alien invaders who were coming to earth
and they're gonna attack us and all
kinds of great stuffs gonna happen so me
and my cohorts we're all gonna go into
space we're all gonna fight these guys
what are we gone for a few days but
don't worry we will save the world and
everything will be fun it's kind of like
okay cool so like they're gonna go find
alien this is gonna be interesting but
what you end up finding out here is that
like none of that stuff's true there are
a couple things that go on and there are
a couple things we need to draw
attention to really most notably the
actions of the boys now the boys being
here are actually tracking down Vick the
veep right and specifically they're
looking for a particular guy and we'll
actually find out who that guy is here
in a second but the crazy thing about
this is that in the middle of all this
homeland ER kind of comes to this
realization and what he realizes here is
that he can pretty much do anything and
there's really nothing anybody can do to
stop him and this this this revelation
kind of comes from a couple of different
places but one of the big things that
comes from is when he basically flies
out into the sky totally naked and then
comes across this trans-pacific airline
right the 747 making its way from Sydney
over to over to America and then he
blasts the things with us with his heat
vision literally destroys the the pilots
in the cockpit and the whole thing goes
crashing down and it explodes and it's
basically like I can do that right and
it's the nature of homeland right like
it's this the reality of the superhero
era that they're living in at the moment
is what you're dealing with here is
you're dealing with this scenario where
you basically have these these
superheroes who don't really have any
traditional weaknesses right there's no
like Superman with kryptonite there's no
Green Lantern with the color yellow that
doesn't really exist here all these
super-powered beings who have no real
weakness whatsoever Vonn American has
positioned itself in a place to where
it's kind of like the Gateway right the
access point whereby these heroes go
from just being individuals who have
powers who gain their abilities from
brought Americans to individuals who now
have acts
- like money and drugs and women and all
these various things I so because that
it gets kind of crazy because what you
end up doing is picking up with the
arrival of Viktor veep himself now I
remember
Viktor veep is the vice president of the
United States but he's a von American
stooge rightly he was specifically put
into the position of becoming vice
president because he can essentially fly
under the radar right I mean when was
the last time you cared about anything
the Vice President did nobody cares what
the vice president does he's basically a
yes-man and there's really nothing more
to it than that
his role is to just say yes to things
right to do what Vaughn American wants
him to do and to really do nothing more
that's why they chose him is because
he's just kind of a simple-minded [ __ ]
he's very basic here and so as a result
of all that you suddenly have huey who
basically gets a phone call from starlet
and here's the irony about all this is
neither of them is being truly honest
with the other about what they do for a
living
huey of course we know as part of the
boys but the cover story he gave her was
that he was like an insurance analyst
basically but i mean people you know a
guy who discovers fraud different things
like that and that's really the only
role that he plays but it's ironic here
because they're both in the same
location they just can't really tell the
other that they're that they're
essentially there or at least any could
but technically like hero gasma is
supposed to be undercover I supposed to
be kept under wraps and no one's
supposed to know about it which kind of
makes sense but in the middle of all
this suddenly like Huey is met by the
arrival of black noir now here's a crazy
thing about all this here we kind of
snuck off a little bit in order to in
order to achieve this at the same time
the rest of the boys are kind of
preparing this particular operation
which we'll talk about here in a second
but like in the middle of all that
Huey while he's talking to Annie and
essentially like standing in the only
sewer system kind of more or less is
like snatched up by black noir who
basically more or less again series will
which is kind of extreme there but at
the same time what you're also getting
is as soon as that happened not really
what happens with Huey but as soon as
this one guy who basically looks like
this like the thing Ben Grimm comes
crashing down into the pool then that's
when the operation starts and the reason
why is because this guy was designed to
be a distraction now in reality he
really is a stand-in for the fit just
like all the other members of his team
are standing for the Fantastic Four he's
really what they're designed to be but
the idea behind this operation is to use
that as a distraction get in get in get
out snatch somebody up and we don't
really know exactly who this person is
supposed to be Huey for the most part
goes missing right I mean you know
experiencing this this heinous situation
he's just kind of cowering in fear of
you of just terrified by this whole
scenario and so ultimately Billy Rogers
not able to find him quite readily
instead he was just sort of dare and
just kind of out doing his own thing
but all this basically comes to a head
when you end up having a Hughie who
basically comes to who essentially wakes
up and then goes out there finally ends
up you know meeting with Billy but
you're only four ability to kind of yell
chastise them a little bit say hey man
what do you do any other crazy stuff but
for us to find out the person they were
going after was a Secret Service agent
by the name of Michael Lucero now this
guy is exceedingly important and the
reason why this is this is important
reason why I chose to do this one is
because this builds off what we saw with
the origin of the superheroes right in
with regards to to Argus the
super-powered beings with regards to the
boys comic are the reason for that is
because while they're interrogating my
Cola syrup
he basically spills the beans right he
spills the beans on on essentially
everything that's going on and what he
ends up saying here is that von American
positioning Vick the veep to basically
kind of ensure that it would eventually
control the White House was not enough
right they had to put him in there then
they had to orchestrate a series of
events or have a hand in series of
events that could basically position him
so that either the president could be
deemed incapable of doing his job
whatever the case is victor veep would
ensure the popularity of Avadh american
and so if you guys recall from our video
we were talking about the origin of
superheroes one of the things that
bought american wanted to do was they
basically wanted to show that
superheroes could be credible defense
against whatever threats happen to be
out there on earth and to get them
involved in the military-industrial
complex and so what ended up happening
is with this guy Michael acero his his
idea was he always want to join the
Secret Service but ultimately what ended
up happening is when he when he joined
up he was assigned to Vick the veep but
this basically goes into the events of
9/11 and the reason why this is
important is because what we talked
about in in the origin of superheroes is
that something happened in the war room
and Dakota Bob who's the sitting
president at the time was the one who is
basically orchestrating the orders and
taking control of the situation in the
whole nine yards the issue with this is
that with Victor V being there the idea
of an American wants to position
superhero so they could be you know
shown as like a credible defense
mechanism against other threats outside
the United States and so in order to
ensure that this happened knowing that
dakota bob was avidly against the idea
of bringing superheroes into the defense
system of the united states that
wouldn't have happened he Mason who is
Victor veep essentially knocked out
Dakota Bob with a fire extinguisher and
when that happened like literally nobody
really saw it happen right things
happened so fast nobody really saw it
all go down all they saw was that Dakota
Bob was essentially knocked unconscious
and because Victor veep was the vice
president essentially he was the next
person in charge and that's when Victor
V basically told everybody
have all the Jets and everything stand
down do not intercept any of these
planes that are coming in through 9/11
and like that was it that's the only
order that they got and because of the
fact of the military for the most part
has to follow the direction of the
commander-in-chief or his immediate
successor in this case the
vice-president the military had to stand
down this opened the doorway for the
seven to show up and to basically try to
stop the 9/11 hijackers now we knew that
kind of went bonkers it kind of flew to
the wayside and really went sideways in
a multitude of different ways if you're
not sure about that
feel free to check out the previous
videos on it they didn't really work out
for Von American exactly as they planned
but it worked out for them nonetheless
it was basically a display to the
general public
superheroes can be more than just come
up with characters right they can
essentially protect the United States
from various threats and so as a result
of that one of the other things that
Michael asura says is there is a
organization called Red River now Red
River is designed to be the boys stand
in for Blackwater which was essentially
like this mercenary team that had his
hand as the pretty nefarious actions at
the very beginnings of the Iraq and
Afghan war but the idea behind this is
at Red River is essentially kind of like
a independent contracting mercenary
organization that was created by and
usually always works for Vaud Americans
but can be licensed out to the
government at times and so as a result
of this in order to ensure that things
went the way they wanted to what Vaughn
Americans started doing was positioning
members of Red River to become Secret
Service agents to basically work on
their behalf a Secret Service agents
what this shows is a Vaught American has
been systematically over the years
getting its fingers in to the White
House and trying to find a way to
control the federal government as it
exists and the result of this is that
really the president at the time a
Dakota Bob made it exceedingly easy and
the reason why he made it easy is
because there were a lot there was a lot
of legislation that was introduced by
Congress and was ultimately passed by
him that essentially allowed this kind
of piece Mealing of congressional
oversight right basically like members
of Congress could receive far more
campaign donations different things like
that which basically allowed different
companies to buy the government in a
variety of different ways to make sure
bills were passed and pays and so well
it wasn't the intention of Dakota Bob to
explicitly explicitly service fought
American ultimately he did like
ultimately he ended up kind of opened in
the doorway and making it possible for
an American to get their foot in and
just kind of go from there and so what
it does following this is it kind of
picks up with the tail end of this right
you have what's called the Subi's which
is which is basically just like the
superhero award ceremony that kind of
goes on here and it's kind of a crazy
thing because you sort of see this great
big huge gathering of all these various
guy
were here but Michael Nocera being
released by the boys I'm really served
the purpose of allowing him to kind of
continue his mission to figure out which
members of The Secret Service Agency are
are like Red River agents and which ones
are legitimately loyal to whoever
they're protecting because the role of
the Secret Service is they're not really
loyal to the president they're not
really loyal to the vice-president
they're loyal to the position regardless
of who's holding that position right so
their job is to protect the President or
the vice president it doesn't matter who
the President or the vice president is
at the time and so as a result of that
it's really kind of working in in the
benefit of bought America the problem
with this is that in the middle of this
whole Subi's of war Homeland er
basically gets up and begins a process
is saying like hey look here's what I
did like I came to this realization but
there's really nothing as stopping out
there's nothing stopping us out there we
could do pretty much anything we want to
but before he spills the beans on it all
and basically says I shot down a
transatlantic airliner because I could
and there's nothing anybody can do to
stop me bought American basically walks
in right like one of their guys
essentially walks in to look at
everything that's going on and that
basically shuts down homeland and the
reason why is because even if homeland
er wanted to make the move and even if
you wanted to basically say we can
conquer everything we can we can tear
everything down and to really incite all
these superheroes to become kind of like
their own vigilante - I had to take the
law into their own hands and do whatever
it is they want to do in absence of
whatever it is that bought American or
the government wants them to do uh he
can't really make that move at the
moment because if he did want American
would pull everything out from under
them right now at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter it's more politics
than anything else but if you're someone
like homeland er who's essentially
unstoppable yes you're one person but
how stoppable are you in the face of
like a hundred superheroes all trying to
fight you at the same time but
ultimately while all this is going down
with regards to everything with homeland
are almost on the verge of like making
his decree and basically rallying all
the superheroes to kind of rise up
against humanity more or less just kind
of say look we're gonna do whatever we
want to do there's nothing you can do to
stop us you also end up having Michael
Lucero who makes his move on the various
agents who were out there that are part
of Red River alongside the boys and so
as a result as a kind of shootout ensues
routed me ultimately Michael asura shot
and killed in the process but what this
basically means is that the the
involvement of Vaud American in the
goings-on of the federal government is
far far more deep reaching than we ever
thought they were our idea was that they
positioned a vice president in there
right lavash presidential stooge a guy
who would just do whatever they told him
to and then ultimately that would do it
all just kind of come to
head what pot American has been planning
is the death of the president to where
they can off Dakota Bob and when that
goes down that in turn that the veep
will take his place he'll serve out the
rest of Dakota Bob's presidency and then
run for election and then have another
eight years possibly under his purview
and essentially broad American
controlling everything that's the plan
that's the idea as WOD American wants to
see it go down which is a huge moment
it's a big thing to basically do here
like the idea of taking out a sitting
president replacing it with your own
with your own puppet and then in turn
controlling the United States like
that's a pretty significant thing to go
down there because what it could do if
an American so chose to do that is by
breathing that superheroes in and then
in turn saying like they're part of the
defense system now they could in turn
use the superheroes to totally conquer
the United States right and then like
basically make themselves a kind of
dictatorship so to speak and so it's
kind of bonkers to see this to see this
whole thing play out because that's kind
of the question is if this is the big
revelation that comes out of everything
that was learned from Michael Lucero and
the question is how do the boys stop
this that's really the the big question
you kind of have to ask here but
whatever you said guys we're bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
count let's explain make sure you guys
to the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
you
[Music]